liebe freunde von visual politik ich
bitte euch heute mein etwas gruseliges
erscheinungsbild zu entschuldigen das
prager visual politik die macht nämlich
nicht nur klasse videos sondern auch mal
klasse partys und diesen so klasse dass
man am nächsten tag nun mal nicht mehr
ganz taufrisch aussehen kann
versucht bitte trotzdem ein anblick zu
ertragen in dem heutigen video geht es
um ein sehr wichtiges problem das nicht
nur internetnutzer in der türkei
betrifft wenn die grundlagen jeder
demokratischen gesellschaft ausfüllen
kann
und lasst uns loslegen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vor kaum einer anderen website waren
lehrer ihre schüler so oft wie vor dicke
pdf a ist wikipedia trotz all ihrer
systemimmanenten schwächen eigentlich
ein wunderwerk der menschheit sie hat
mittlerweile das wissen ganze generation
geprägt und was hätte ich zu meiner
schulzeit dafür gegeben ein solch
schnelles und umfassendes lernt tool zu
haben man muss aber nicht unbedingt so
stein als sein wie ich ohne dieses
gefühl zu kennen da sind gar nicht dafür
reicht ist in der türkei zu leben und
kein problem zu haben denn bis zum 15
januar 2020 hat mit türkische
internetnutzer keine zugang zur größten
wissens website der welt wikipedia war
durch den staat seit jahren gesperrt
die türkei hebt verbot von wikipedia
nach fast drei jahren auf bloomberg es
geht um dass der sätze nummer fünf 1651
über die regulierung von
internetveröffentlichungen und die
bekämpfung von straftaten die durch
solche veröffentlichungen gegangen
werden ja so schön verklausuliert ist
der offiziellen aber dieses gesetz ist
dass man ehrlicherweise auch einfach
internetzensurgesetz hätte legen können
da klingt sogar eine erste wort
schöpfung wie netzwerk durchsetzungs
gesetz ehrlicher nach zensur und
totalität nun aber zurück zur türkei
das türkische gesetz nummer fünf 1651
wurde im mai 2007 verabschiedet und im
februar 2010 nochmals verschärft wird
der staat die zugabe seine bürger zu
online-inhalten noch besser unterdrücken
kann
und dann legten die zensoren los als
gäbe es kein morgen
mai 2015 nur ein jahr später hatte die
türkische regierung bereits mehr als
80.000 websites blockiert bis ende 2018
stieg diese zahl auf mehr als 245.000 61
an genau eine viertel million websites
die von der regierung eines landes
blockiert wurde
das derzeit man höre und staune noch ein
begriff ist der europäischen union
beizutreten
nun das wird mit sehr hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit nie passiert
zumindest nicht solange erdogan an der
macht ist denn er ist auch der oberste
schirmherr der türkischen internetzensur
aber moment mal
die dinge sind mal wieder etwas
komplexer denn erdogan war nicht immer
ein fan von unterdrückung und
totalitarismus ganz im gegenteil
[Musik]
die rückkehr der diktatur wenn es einen
politischen führer in der westlichen
welt gibt der in den letzten jahren
seine meinung ideen und botschaften
öfter wechselte als eine unterwäsche
natürlich nur im sprichwörtlichen sinne
groß an herrn böhme man dann war dies
recep tayyip erdogan
denn lange zeit langen all seine
botschaften wie die folgende wir wollen
beweisen dass ein muslimisches land
demokratisch transparent und mit der
modernen welt kompatibel sein kann
recep tayyip erdogan klingt doch toll
nun dies waren jene botschaften mit
denen er nach außen eindruck schinden
wollte er aber rief er schon losungen
wie die folgen werden
die demokratie ist wie ein zug wenn man
sein ziel erreicht steigt man aus
fremdheit erdogan überrascht nun es gibt
nicht den allerkleinsten grund auch nur
eine sekunde zu glauben erdogan sei ein
hund der nur bett ganz und gar nicht ist
es nicht geradezu erfrischend ist auch
mal mit einem politiker zu tun zu haben
der manchmal auch tut was er sagt und
kommt darauf an auf welche art von
erfrischung man steht denn in diesem
fall steht der mann vor allem dann zu
seinem wort wenn es um zensur und die
rückabwicklung demokratischer prinzipien
geht seht euch mal folgendes an
[Musik]
die türkei verurteilt 24 journalisten
wegen angeblicher terrorverbindungen zu
gefängnisstrafen die meisten
journalisten arbeiteten zur
nachrichtenorganisationen die fethullah
gülen nahestanden einem geistlichen der
zurückgezogen in einer kleinstadt in
pennsylvania liegt die türkische
regierung behauptet kühlen führe eine
geheime gewaltige bewegung an die es auf
den sturz von präsident recep tayyip
erdogan abgesehen hätte die new york
times
solche vorgänge sind in der türkei
mittlerweile an der tagesordnung sie
bestätigen nur das was praktisch niemand
bestreiten würde jedes land das als die
fortschrittlichste und freieste
demokratie in der islamischen welt weist
heute auf bestem wege in die abgründe
der autokratie oder zumindest in einer
dieser neuen politischen mischformen
welche in vielen ländern in mode
gekommen sind so demokratisch wie nötig
so bricht konform wie möglich
[Musik]
und natürlich muss man um eine solche
autokratie im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert zu konsolidieren als erstes
das internet kontrolliert das wäre
sozusagen das aller erste kapitel in
einem internationalen polit bestseller
diktatur für dummies nun was genau geht
in der türkei eigentlich vor sich ist
die lage wirklich so ernst besteht eine
hoffnung dass die einschränkungen des
freien zugangs zum internet nicht noch
weiter voran schreiten die wikipedia
zumindest wurde ja wieder erlaubt nun
das alles denn in diesem video ergründen
wie alles begann
[Musik]
stell dir vor du warst eines tages
morgens auf und erfährt dass seine
regierung hacker erneuert hat die dich
ausspionieren sollen sie interessiert
sich dabei zum beispiel für alle von ihr
besuchten websites ohne das ist ziemlich
genau das was 2015 ganz normalen bürger
und der türkei passiert ist ihre
regierung beauftragte eine hacker firma
den datenverkehr türkische
internetnutzer für mehr als drei jahre
zu protokollieren
aber sein wird der das ganze kam nicht
gerade überraschend
erdogan hatte praktisch von anfang an
mit einige sehr konkrete und klar
formuliert pläne im kopf um ab dem jahr
2013 die totale kontrolle über das
türkische internet zu erlernen und dafür
müssen wir ganz so weit schauen 2008
erwischte es zum beispiel youtube die
türkei blockierte damals die
videoplattform weil in ein paar videos
irgendwie mustafa kemal atatürk der
gründer der modernen türkei beleidigt
wurde und diese sperre 1000 nicht
weniger als zwei jahre aber das sollte
erst ein anfang sein denn den türkischen
präsidenten glitt die lage im land
zunehmend aus den händen zwischen mai
und august 2008 10 kam es zu massiven
protesten gegen die türkische regierung
die auf dem taksim-platz in istanbul
stattfinden
[Musik]
ursprünglich das ziel die zerstörung des
geoparks für den bau eines
einkaufszentrums zu verhindern daher
wurden die proteste auch als die gysi
proteste bezeichnet aber wie reaktion
der behörden war so heftig dass das was
als protest zur erhaltung eines packs
begann schnell zu einer ganzen bewegung
gegen den autoritarismus der regierung
wurde um die reine vorstellung von der
brutalität ist durchgreifens zu gehen
mindestens 22 menschen starben mehr als
8000 menschen wurden verletzt und
weitere 4100 wurden in mehr als 90
städten des ganzen landes verhaftet auf
diese weise spielte sich die erste große
widerstands reaktion der türkischen
zivilgesellschaft gegen den autoritären
erdogan hat das internet spielte dabei
für beide seiten eine entscheidende
rolle
während der proteste beobachtete die
türkische regierung die trends auf
twitter äußerst genau und zögerte nicht
nutzer des populären social networks
sofort zu verhaften sobald sie irgendwas
negatives über die regierung kostet
[Musik]
die regierung schaltete auch die 3g
antennen aus um zu verhindern dass sich
die demonstranten untereinander
koordinieren und weißt du was im grunde
genommen war das der wendepunkt der
moment in dem der türkische staatschef
so richtig gefallen an der totalen
kontrolle von internet und
telekommunikation in seinem land fand
soest erdogan schon kurze zeit später
2014 in die novellierung des gesetzes
1641 um twitter ganz zu blocken twitter
in der türkei geblockt bbc tja wie du
siehst alles sehr demokratisch
meinungsfreiheit steht an oberster
stelle und natürlich weißt du wie solche
dinge dann eskalieren wenn ein herrscher
beginnt die meinungsfreiheit zu
beschneiden das internet zu zensieren
und das gesetz so zu missbrauchen das
nach belieben tun kann was er gerade
will geschieht dies nicht nur ein zwei
oder dreimal sondern systematisch die
türkische regierung blockte ihren
bürgern beispielsweise februar 2020 nach
einem türkischen luftangriffen syrien
erneut im ganzen sozialen medien auf gar
keinen fall sollte jemand die
gelegenheit bekommen die regierung zu
kritisieren türkei blockiert 16 stunden
lang den zugang zu sozialen medien nach
dem luftangriff auf syrien euronews
diese praktiken werden immer üblicher so
dass türkische bürger nicht einmal mehr
sicher sind wenn sie zugang zu ihren
sozialen netzwerken haben werden weil
die regierung sieht ein und schaltet die
ist ihr gerade gefällt und macht jetzt
bitte nicht den fehler die türkei in
einen topf mit ländern wie saudi arabien
oder anzuwerfen ja in solchen ländern
sind derartige dinge ganz und gebe aber
die türkei war viele jahre lang wirklich
auf besten wege zu einer vollständigen
aufgeklärten demokratie heranzureifen
sie war der hoffnungsschimmer am
horizont der islamischen welt
und nun gehört dies der vergangenheit an
tatsächlich bewertetes freedom house die
freiheit des internets in der türkei mit
mageren 37 von 100 punkten
dies war zwar eine leichte verbesserung
gegenüber den vorjahren aber weniger als
40 punkte bedeuten dass das internet in
einem land quasi geblockt ist
[Musik]
und das internet ist total nun mal ein
zentrales medium zur freien
meinungsbildung und damit fester
bestandteil einer demokratie in einem
land mit internet zensur kann man
folglich nicht mehr von einer demokratie
sprechen und da lässt die türkei vor
allem mit strikter inhaltskontrolle
ständigen verletzungen der rechte von
internetuser der privatsphäre und der
freiheit des zugangs zu
regierungskritischen inhalten eine
regierung welche kritik an ihr und
verbindet kann eben nicht mehr
demokratisch sein
tja wie aber sieht es berüchtigte gesetz
nummer 5650 genau aus welche
implikationen hat es in der praxis auf
den alltag der türken das alles erst
hast du jetzt
zensur und ihre alltägliche wirkung
wie irgendwas die art und weise die
türken im internet surfen für immer
verändert hat dann war es eben jenes
gesetzes 5151 dieses gesetz bestimmt auf
welche art der türkische staat den
freien zugang seiner bürger zum internet
aber auch inhalten auch schilling
plattformen wie netflix unterdrücken er
schreibt vor dass alle inhalte die über
das internet gestreamt werden die
internetradio filme und serien von rtk
dem obersten rundfunk und fernsehrat der
türkei lizenziert werden müssen
tatsächlich mussten die großen lokalen
svi plattform die motive oder
ausländische die netflix neue lizenzen
beantragen um weiterhin im land tätig
sein zu können auf diese weise weil der
stadt in der lage die plattformen und
inhalten die bereits in betrieb waren zu
überprüfen und ihre inhalte moralischen
standards zu unterwerfen schau dir am
besten direkt den wortlaut eines der
paragraphen dieses gesetzes ziel dieser
regelung ist es die methoden und
grundsätzliche regelung der präsentation
und bereitstellung von rundfunk
fernsehen und abrufdienste der erteilung
von lizenzen an medien diese anbieter
der erteilung von sende aufträgen an
plattform verwalter und der aufsicht
über die betreffenden sendungen
festzulegen gesetzt nummer fünf 1651
ohne im falle von netflix einer
plattform die etwa anderthalb millionen
nutzer in der türkei hat muss das
unternehmen um seine dienst weiterhin
anbieten zu können eine lokale
niederlassung gründen die den betrieb
übernimmt und 0,5 prozent ihrer
einnahmen an die türkische regierung
dafür aber das ist nicht das schlimmste
daran wenn alle inhalte müssen von einem
regierungs abhängigen organ abgesegnet
werden dem obersten rundfunk und
fernsehrat der unter anderem für den
schutz der öffentlichen moral zuständig
ist und welchen zweck diese moral dienen
soll ist mehr als klar dem machterhalt
erdogan
wenn alles und jeder der sich ihm in den
weg stellt wird kurzerhand als
unmoralisch gebrandmarkt und wegzensiert
ja kernelemente der demokratie die
religions- und meinungsfreiheit kritik
der regierungspolitik pluralismus und
minderheitenschutz das alles ist
ebenfalls unmoralisch geht wie die
opposition soll eben so klein wie
möglich gehalten werden damit erdogan
dann bei wahlen als demokratisch
gewählter sieger glänzen kann aber
demokratie besteht nun mal nicht nur aus
rheinböllen die alle paar jahre
stattfinden ohne all die anderen
demokratischen grundsätze ist eine
regierungsform keine legitime demokratie
mehr auf jeden fall haben wir es hier
mit einer momentaufnahme der lage mit
uns zu tun die sehr beunruhigend ist
denn die einstige hoffnung dass eine
demokratische regierung am ende einer
führungsrolle im nahen osten übernehmen
würde ist in etwa so schnell verflogen
die erdogan sich als allmächtiger
kriegsherr entpuppt hat heute ist somit
klar dass die türkischen internetnutzer
einem sehr sehr harten kampf um die
freiheit vor sich haben so und jetzt
bist du an der reihe
schreibt uns in den kommentaren ob du
glaubst die türkei könne doch noch eine
trendumkehr zur demokratie hin bekommen
immerhin sind sehr große teile vor allem
der urban bevölkerung bereit für eine
rückkehr ihres landes zu einem
freiheitlichen system zu kämpfen und wie
sieht es in deinem eigenen land aus
welche eingriffe in die freie
meinungsäußerung
siehst du als grenzwertig oder
demokratie gefährden
wie immer freuen wir uns auf eure
angeregte diskussion und ist ihr dass
jede woche neue informative videos für
euch vorbereitet und veröffentlichen
wenn ihr also keines dieser aktuellen
updates verpassen wollt abonniert bitte
bis wolkig und drückt danach bitte auch
auf die klingel taste um keines davon zu
verpassen wenn euch dieses video etwas
gebracht hat dann gibt es auch einen
daumen hoch bis zum nächsten
[Musik]
[Applaus]